[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs
dois avouer que
un écoutant avec beaucoup de plaisir
ont précédé
le passé mon temps à me demander qu'est
ce que je vais bien pouvoir leur dire
il
et qui encore plus dit il pour moi c'est
de parler de mon
rêve pas
y arrive pas
je trouve que ceux qui arrivent font
preuve de beaucoup de courage
obligation
parce que nous avons tous en nous
dans notre parcours
dans notre histoire
et moments de joie
et de douleur
et nec qui disait
la plupart des hommes
aux mains de s'embarquer ne songe pas à
la tempête
le résumé de notre vie
alors moi je suis
monsieur
kalifa gassama diaby
je suis né à kindia
je suis
né dans une
vieille et modeste famille ya quelqu'un
est un ami dans la salle qui m'a fait
comprendre tout à l'heure
oubliée veut dire que tu était destiné à
être marabout
parce que mon père l'ait
ludique il l'est parce que
j'ai quitté ce matin qu'il dia pour être
ici pour honorer l'engagement que j'ai
pris pour participer à cet événement
alors
j'ai vu le sous thème
la constance et l'intégrité
faut bâtir une nation de rêve
je me suis dit d'un spirou ne me fais
jamais de cadeaux parce que on me donne
des problématiques qui sont extrêmement
il a abordé parce qu'on se fait toujours
plus d'amis en les abordant
alors
moi je suis le site de formation
et puis un jour
toulouse
nous avons appris avec
beaucoup de regret
la disparition du général lansana conté
et j'étais membre fondateur d'un groupe
de réflexion sur le continent africain
qui s'appelait le gr k
nous passions toute la nuit
les intellectuels africains
sénégalais tchadiens nigériens d'inr
ivoiriens maliens
rêvé rêvé pour la transformation de
l'afrique
et nous étions cinq ados vont nous
dirigions sévère extrêmement sévère mais
aussi ambitieux avec beaucoup dit au
pays
après avoir passé dix ans ça met les
pieds en guinée j'ai décidé de rentrer
visiter mon pays d'origine mon pays de
naissance
arrivé en guinée
pendant la transition
des senti le vent de l'espoir souffler
et on s'est dit enfin
ce pays va pouvoir
emprunter un nouveau chemin non pas que
rien n'a été fait parce que jamais on ne
peut dire que rien n'a été fait
et jamais on ne peut reprocher à ceux
qui ont gouverné ce pays ne pas avoir
aimé ce pays c'est pas possible
c'est juste les approches les dynamiques
les souris sion les méthodes
et le caractère des uns et des autres
qui sont différents
et puis avec d'autres amis africains
nous avons décidé de mettre en place en
guinée une ong
noël j'ai
un observatoire
chargé de s'impliquer dans la culture
démocratique l'éducation à la culture
démocratique
n'était pas facile
je me souviens
avoir fait une interview à la rtg
par le biais d'un ami qui va présenter
un ami à l'autre et puis un journaliste
à ces rêveurs aussi
parce que il a cru au discours ambiant
[Musique]
consistait à 10 désormais c'est la
liberté
comme pour se différencier du passé et
puis il a eu l'audace de me donner la
parole
j'ai parlé
et il a failli perdre son poste le
lendemain
appelé
il m'a dit
même le m'appelle plus et devient plus
me voir
la guinée
alors je me suis dit metz
va pas perdre encore cette occasion de
remettre ce pays sur le chemin de
l'espérance réel objectives non pas des
discours parce que quand on aime ce pays
et qu'on regarde l'eau kashi le gâchis
nous vivons dans ce pays les talents
cachés
les espérances des torrides
les rêves d'autrui à chaque fois c'est
le même discours
alors moi je suis habitué
ceux qui sont gentils
me traite de rêveurs
et qui sont pas gentils
mais très peu fou
parce qu'ils disent c'est pas la peine
il comprendra pas il n'y arrivera pas
parce qu'il ne fait pas de concessions
et on se demande
de quelle concession par l'otan
on sait sur quoi
non quand se battre
alors à l'époque
je m'impliquais naïvement quand il y
avait des manifestations
j'étais c'était une forme de folie un
peu romantique et ces jeunes africains
qui ont grandi en europe et qui ont
toujours ce souci de sauver le monde et
puis moi je vais me retrouver au milieu
des gaz lacrymo qui tombaient et puis
les gendarmes le général baldé
à qui je dois rendre hommage ici qui a
accepté à l'époque de travailler avec
moi j'étais sur le terrain avec eux
j'ai vu des choses
la brutalité
de la violence je ne reconnais pas mon
pays de naissance
je ne reconnais pas la taupe a cité une
nuit des guinéens à faire preuve de
violence et de cruauté
ok
je décide de quitter ce pays
est demandée pères
vais rentrer en guinée
et puis je me souviens soir
je reçois l'appel de monsieur
qui était très proche
président de la transition de l'époque
et puis il me dit
président souhaite vous rencontrer
j'étais sur leur route en partance pour
qu'il ya
alors je dois avouer que j'étais content
je me suis dit
je vais pouvoir lui dire ce que j'ai sur
le coeur
j'arrive à kindia c'était un vendredi
je m'empresse de raconter cette histoire
à mon papa
le sens sceptiques on est vendredi
me dit rien
il avait un de vous le dire
samedi il ne dit rien
dimanche matin je m'apprêtais à quitter
qu'il y a il me fait appeler
me dit
pas vraiment rendez vous avec lui je dis
oui
je pense que une bonne idée
un président 7e voir et lire oui mais je
connais mon caractère et je vois 100
caractères je pense que ça se passera
mal
alors évidemment
j'ai suivi le conseil de mon papa
et j'ai fait une lettre que j'ai remis à
l'intermédiaire vol au président une
lettre qui était faite de beaucoup de
respect mais j'ai pu trouver des raisons
de ne pas y aller
puis jour
était à paris je reçois à l'appel de
quelqu'un qui me dit après bien entendu
les élections et puis
s'en est suivie
mais dit le président alpha condé
souhaite vous voir un guinée moi je suis
à paris je suis pas un dîner oui mais il
veut vous voir
alors
on dit que connu à paris
je rentre en guinée
et il m'envoie des émissaires
me dit
[Musique]
est nommé ministre des droits de l'homme
avant de discuter de 16h à 00h30
ma première réaction
rigoler c'est pas possible
on comprend pas et permet dit mais
pourquoi c'est pas possible
je crois que celui qui m'a présenté tout
à l'heure la très bien dit
vous ne pouvez pas me nommer ministre
des droits de l'homme pour deux raisons
je ne suis pas le profil
et en plus c'est une anomalie
institutionnels
vous me demander d'être ministre des
droits de l'homme
parce que vous pensez que je peux vous
défendre vous vous trompez
par contre si vous voulez vraiment
quelqu'un pour jouer ce rôle moi je
connais quelques uns en guinée je peux
vous le présentez vous
alors évidemment les discussions
continuent pendant presque six à huit
mois
moi je ne veux pas
il veut pas et beaucoup de guinéens sont
témoins puisqu'ils sont intervenus pour
me convaincre d'être ministre j'étais
convaincu que c'était une fonction
ingrate
elle n'était pas pour celui qui n'était
pas attaché à son intégrité morale
et à son souci de respecter
rôle
y avait un défaut j'étais un jeune
universitaire qui était soucieux
de la validité des arguments que je dois
utiliser dans ma fonction je n'étais pas
et d'ailleurs toujours pas un politique
et pour défendre les droits de l'homme
j'avais le souci de la cohérence
intellectuelle de la cohérence morale
mais aussi de sa validité juridique
donc il n'y avait pas de place pour les
arrangements
et il joue
guinéens savent
les dénommés hommes ont encore
le décret est sorti je l' ai appris à
18h30
quelques mois envoyer
un message très court il m'a dit c'est
ce soir tu n'as pas le choix
alors j'habitais
vers la cbg dans un appartement
et j'étais tellement embêté que j'ai
quitté 19h30 mon appartement pour aller
me cacher dans un restaurant un ville
car le décret est sorti on était un peu
dans le noir il y avait la télé et puis
avait des hauts cadres qui étaient là
et quand j'ai entendu mon nom j'étais là
ils ne me connaissent pas et on était
dans le noir et puis j'entends des
quelqu'un dire enfin à ce type là il a
tellement parlé qu'il a obtenu ce qu'il
voulait
ça
alors j'étais là côté on y voit là c'est
ce qu'il voulait il a obtenu on va enfin
être tranquille
et moi j'étais là je me disais
mince si le président savait qu'il à
faire entrer le loup dans la bergerie
pourtant j'ai tout fait pour le
convaincre mais je crois profondément
qu'il était sincère vous savez il ya des
moments de sincérité spontanée on est
sincère maintenant deux secondes après
on les plus
ils l'étaient ils l'étaient évidemment
il n'y a pas de naïveté il avait aussi
une difficulté politique notamment
vis-à-vis des institutions
internationales et qu'il avait besoin de
moraliser sa gouvernance et de donner un
crédit moral à nos partenaires qu'il y
avait une volonté politique de changer
alors de ce point de vue là j'étais une
caution morale
parfois il y avait des gens
y pensez à me critiquer en dix ans les
miss gassama mais c'est une caution
morale mais je le savais que jamais pu
mais enfin puisque j'étais là
toute association humaine est une
association d'intérêt
le président avait un intérêt politique
à nommer quelqu'un à ce poste qui est en
poste symbolique très important pour un
pays qui est dans une dynamique de
construction démocratique
pour moi
puisque j'avais ménat le pied dedans
c'était une occasion d'essayer
beaucoup de modestie mais d'essayer de
changer un certain nombre de choses
je dois avouer de 2012
2015 avant
l'élection du deuxième du second mandat
j'ai eu beaucoup de difficulté bien
entendu beaucoup de souffrance beaucoup
d'épreuves on ne peut pas tous des
raconter parce que bien entendu je
sommes aussi astreint à un devoir
républicain de réserve sur un certain
nombre de choses mais je dois avouer que
pendant deux ans et demi
le président alpha condé à l'époque
avait une grande écoute
d'arrivée que ma position chez lui
comptait bien plus important était bien
plus importante que la position du reste
de l'équipe
la guinée est un pays étonnant
les étonnants
alors
on lui disait au début
mais que sa main il est avec celle où
vous voyez bien il veut pas qu'on
interdise les manifestations puis après
on disait gaza mois il avait cydia après
une dizaine d'hommes il avait piraté
le président de la république il est en
forme et
services il sait très bien c'était vrai
ce qui n'est pas vrai alpha condé
imparfait politique savait que c'était
faux et on avait un accord après le
décret sorti la corse était si vous me
désavouer je démissionne
et entendu
un politicien malin qu'il était à
l'époque
et il ne le fait jamais mais évidemment
il donnait la balle aux autres à son
entourage
qui voilà qui faisait
des attaques des insultes des manoeuvres
et puis voilà tout
qu'en disent la vérité mais cela nous
renvoie une problématique dans notre
pays c'est la détestation des gens qui
savent vieille tradition qui n'est
pourquoi parce que ceux qui savent sont
fondamentalement des gens libres
la liberté et le savoir c'est au couple
parfait quand vous savez vous savez ce
que vous valez et moralement et
éthiquement et intellectuellement il ya
des choses auxquelles vous rabaissez pas
alors appelé m'ont dit tu vas lui
l'édifice y avait moi je n'ai pas pu
aller compliquée être chicha difficile
drague et et quand il est comme
mais alors
vous regardez la guinée mais elle est où
la machine
avec une fois ne comprennent rien où
sont ceux qui combiné à loix cotées sur
ce
jeu serait
finalement le pauvre il est de ceux
berlin après les autres les changes
devait
et jaunâtre et c'est ce que nous
explique aujourd'hui
un qui ont accompagné ce monsieur
à rester parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
remplacera celle du lait explique
aujourd'hui les nouvelles autorités qui
sont là avait une mission sacrée de
renouveler la classe politique parce que
les anciens sont mauvais ils ont soutenu
quelqu'un qui avait 80 ans
souffre et qui de ce fait
ça c'est au niveau que la société
et comment voulez vous qu'une société
qu'une bonne base l'exemplarité
accéder un bien-être
il n'y a pas de bien-être sans la vérité
un jour moi j'étais reconduit quatre
fois d'un vernon
asseoir
un décret qui sort
vous assure petit sur mon honneur à
chaque fois que j'ai entendu mon nom à
la télé comme ministre j'en avais peur
parce que j'avais peur de ne pas être à
la hauteur
soit
dans le midi avenue de lire le décret je
suis moins des mouches
des voisins en toute bonne foi sont
venus pour danser dans la paume
et j'adorerais que gervais et puis le
drap demander un sou à manga mais aura
un ministre
et rival à neymar il fallait
et puis l'opposition légale il fallait
les dix maires un invité à balansun
analyse des résultats l'on lui là où va
le payer un chien parce que victor
wooten chrono mais green a fait des
profits et aironi ita maskass aalok
laval funambulisme ça c'est acquis mais
si je dois conclure
je peux prendre à paris
et à ça je m'adresse aux jeunes
ne voudrais pas donner des concerts mais
aidé il a offert aux tendres en fait ce
qu'ils ont pu
la nasa si au moins deux que je connais
bien que j'ai approché
les jeunes
avaient deux chemins
celui de chemin qualifie d'
fait très mal à la ferté autre honneur
votre liberté
l'injustice
d'y arriver
j'aurai ce que vous voulez vous aurait
trahi votre nation nous avec chemin
devrait
finir à ce pays finira sur ce chemin sur
le chemin de la vérité et de la justice
le chemin de l'intimité
chemin qui consiste à ce que tu as pris
la justice soit la même pour tous ce
que la liberté soit réelle
c'est ainsi que nous pouvons construire
une nation
nous n'avons pas cette nation qui a
précédé nos états nous avons par notre
volonté par la vie de faire ce site est
d'avoir des valeurs
avant c'est une dynamique une idée
nouvelle ce n'est qu'à ce prix là
seulement hamas ont pris vers ce pays
changera mais jamais dans l'inconstance
et dans nos membres et
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]